- Hey everyone, this is Luka.
I'm really excited to tell you
that my course on the basics
of R (for ecologist) is up and running.
So if you're an ecologist and
you're just getting started
with R and feeling that
frustration of the learning curve
and just need something that
can take you by the hand to
really understand the
solid fundamentals of using
RforEcology, check out my course,
just go to RforEcology.com
there's a link also down below
and hope to see you there.
(ethereal music)
Hey everyone, Luka here today,
I'm just gonna give you a
really short tutorial on the
basics of simple linear regression with R.
So the most basic linear
regression models the
relationship between
two numeric variables.
And so to begin with first,
we're going to load some data
and we'll just use the data
function in R, data to load
a data set called trees.
And so when we run that line of code,
we get these trees data here.
So these data represent the
measurements of the diameter,
height and volume of
31 black cherry trees.
So note that girth is actually
the diameter breast height
of each tree measured in inches.
Height is the tree height in
feet and volume is the volume
of the wood in cubic feet.
So just for a little bit of clarity there,
let's rename the column
names of that data frame.
And so we'll just do that by going names
so if we run the names function
that shows us what those
column names are, but within that,
we're going to replace those names with
DBH for diameter breast height in inches,
height in feet and volume in feet cubed.
Alright, so now if we run that
and we take a look at
this data frame again,
we'll see that we've successfully
changed the column names.
Alright, so for the basic
linear regression let's model
how the tree diameter changes
as the tree grows taller.
So first we're gonna start
out by writing what we
actually want to model.
So we want to know how DBH varies?
We want to know how DBH varies
as a function of tree height?
And so we can write it out just like that,
and we can actually use these
column names to make it a
little bit more specific.
So how does DBH and inches vary
as a function of tree height?
And note that I use this
little squiggly sign here,
the Tilde or Tilde on my keyboard.
I'm not sure where it is on all keyboards,
but on my keyboard, it's
just under the Escape key
on the top left part of the keyboard.
And I hold down Shift
and press that key under
the Escape key to get this Tilde symbol,
and you'll see why it's important
to know about this Tilde
symbol in a moment,
but you can read this symbol as
is a function of.
So now we can look at this
statement right here and say,
DBH in inches is a
function of height in feet.
And so we can think of our
hypothesis for this regression as
being this model that
we've just come up with.
Another way to think
about it is DBH in inches
is the Y variable, height
in feet is the X variable.
And so the Y variable or DBH
in inches is also the dependent
or the response variable.
And so we can say, how does the Y variable
depend or respond to the X variable?
Now, it's also important to
note that we are not drawing any
conclusions about the causal relationship
between DBH and tree height.
The linear regression analysis
simply allows us to test the
correlation or association
of these two variables,
but it doesn't really tell us
about what is affecting what.
So let's begin by
visualizing the relationship
of DBH and height.
And so the neat thing is we
can use this formula here
this is a function of this
to make the plot as well.
So we'll just use the plot
function and then we'll say,
DBH in inches is a function of,
whenever I say is a function of,
it'll refer to this Tilde symbol.
DBH in inches is a
function of height in feet.
And then we'll add one more argument here
indicating the data set
that this comes from
so the data frame.
Data equals trees.
And so let's run this line
of code and there we have it.
A simple plot showing the
relationship between DBH
on the Y axis, remember
DBH was the Y variable here
and height in feet on the X axis.
So as height changes, so does DBH.
Apparently so it looks like there might be
some kind of positive relationship there,
but that's what the
linear regression is for.
Let's see if there is actually
a significant relationship there.
Also actually, before we move on,
I'm not a big fan of these open circles,
I think it looks a little
better when the circles are
closed, unless you have a
lot of overlapping points.
For example, here we have
two overlapping points,
which might be harder to see
if the circles are filled in,
but I think that's a small
enough sacrifice to make this
plot look a little better.
So we'll just add in one
more argument here, going.
Pch equals 16 and that'll just
make the points filled in.
There we go, so to do
the regression analysis,
all we have to do is actually
take the contents of this plot
function and put it inside an lm function,
which stands for linear mode.
So we'll just copy this.
And we also have to refer to the data
so we'll add this in as well.
And we're not actually plotting anything,
so we don't need this pch parameter here.
But now if we run this,
we get some of the results of the model.
We actually get the estimate
for the coefficient,
for the intercept and the slope
as it's affected by height
in this model.
So it's not a lot to work with yet,
but we can save this as its own objects,
so we'll just call it nod,
and then we can apply the
summary function to mod.
And when we run that,
we get some more interesting
information here.
So first we can see the
distribution of the residuals or the
unexplained variation in the model.
With the minimum value of the residual,
the maximum, the median,
and the first quartile
and third quartile range.
But below that, it gets more interesting.
Here, we have a table of the coefficient.
So again, before without
running summary function,
we just got this value for
the intercept coefficient
and the slope coefficient,
how height is associated with DBH.
Then in this second column,
we have the standard error
around that estimate of the coefficient.
Then we have the test
statistic in this case,
T value for each of these estimates.
And finally, maybe what everyone's really
wanting to look for is the P value
or the significance of
each of these coefficients.
So to think about these
coefficients and what the
significance means, think of it as
what a linear model actually is.
Linear model is simply Y = a + bX.
So to model a straight line
or linear line as described
by a linear model, you
need two coefficients.
First, you have this intercept
value or the A in this case,
which represents where the
line crosses over zero.
And then you have this B
coefficient or the slope
coefficient, which is multiplied by X
to show you the rate at which that line
or the angle at which that
line changes with respect to X.
So what a linear regression
actually does is it tries to
optimize the value of the
intercept and the slope
to create a line that best
describes this relationship
of points between height and DBH.
And then we can use a
statistical test to see if these
coefficients are actually
significantly different from zero.
So after this little table
here we have a little bit
more information, here we've
got these significant codes,
which are just these asterisk
symbols placed at the end of
the P value to quickly
visualize which of these
might be statistically significant.
But then down here, we have
the residual standard error,
which indicates the variation
of unexplained variance
around the regression line.
Then we have the Multiple R-squared,
which can be thought of as
the proportion of variance
in the data that can be
explained by the model.
So you can ignore the
Adjusted R-squared for now,
if you're just starting out,
maybe I'll talk about
that in a future lesson.
And then finally we have the
F-statistic and P value that
tests whether all the coefficients
in the model are zero.
So next, let's actually add
this best fit line to this plot
since we can see that height
is actually a significant
coefficient, excuse me,
the slope is a significant
coefficient suggesting that
height is significantly
associated with diameter breast height.
So let's go ahead and plot that line.
Just go back to our script here.
And so to add a line to this model,
all you have to do is run the
original plot that we created.
So I'll just run this one more time.
And then add in the function abline.
Remember the A and the B that I was using
to explain how linear model works.
So abline uses a slope and an
intercept to create a line.
And abline actually will take
the model that we had
fit as its main argument
and create the line
from those coefficients.
So there it is, that is the best fit line
through these points.
So finally, let's say
that you need to extract
a table with the regression results.
So here's a cool trick for
quickly extracting a neat table
using the package called broom.
So first you need to install.packages
and run this if you haven't
installed broom yet.
If you have installed it,
you don't ever have to run it again,
unless you re-install R on a new machine
or uninstall your
packages for some reason.
So I'm just gonna command that out,
but after you finished installing it,
run library broom to load up that package.
So you have to run the library
function each time you want
to load up a package, but the install is
only the very first time you
install it on your machine.
And then we're gonna use
this function called tidy
to create a table of the
results to extract a neat table
of the results from our model.
And so now the argument will
just be mod again, our model.
And so note that this table
is actually called A tibble,
which is better than a normal data frame,
but that's for another lesson.
So thanks for watching this video,
if you liked it and would
like to see more like it
just hit subscribe below.
If you want to see my full
courses on R (for ecologists),
just see the link below and otherwise,
I hope you have a
fantastic rest of your day.